da asks do you feel It's still a
necessary call to Action to Push
subscribers from social Channels to a
website or newsletter signup da Who says
I Ever thought It was a necessary call
to Action cuz The answer is I didn't and
I don't  no I don't no I didn't What I
mean by That is sure I think it's a good
idea to Push to a website Right now
especially If you're selling something
on that website But in a world where you
can buy that same  product right on
twitter right on Facebook Do you
necessarily need to lep somebody to your
site to make them buy that when when
it's native right for them and they
could just buy it in there no The answer
is no isn't it cuz friction sucks right
friction  sucks and consumers do not want
friction so anything that allows you to
execute within the place You're in
That's What You're going to like and so
My Answer to your question is less and
less every day people say Gary Why
aren't you  driving people to Gary
vu.com Why are you putting out content
on YouTube Why are you putting out
content on medium Why are you putting
content LinkedIn Because I want
awareness So I'm putting out content for
awareness and to build relationships
With All Of You  That's what I'm doing
and thus What That is doing is creating
a scenario Where those Channels allow me
to do that Just because i'm not driving
them to my doc you know many people Give
You Bad marketing advice that say you
have to drive  to your website for what
to collect the email last time i checked
a tweet card that collects email has
been the most efficient way that I've
collected email better than driving
to.com for what what you sell
Advertising on your site If you're
selling Advertising on your site then
Maybe That's the thing You can do But
you can also sell Advertising to people
within your social Channels and run that
arbitrage so the fact of the matter
is that I think people Just not really
that educated on What they'  re Trying to
achieve and so I've Never been worried
about forcing somebody to a comom unless
that was the right strategy At The Right
Time to drive the result the fact that
even ecommerce buying within a tweet and
a facebook post has now gotten to the
plat has eliminated a lot of the reasons
that you have to drive
Somebody